as for the narrow-minded overpaid fools
at media matters and
vox who want to scare all elected
democrats away from appearing on this
show
our next guest tweeted this scathing
takedown
perfect illustration of the stunted
vapid mentality of dem party outlets
the vox video dance maligns one of the
only anti-war dems rokhana for
prioritizing crafting an
anti-imperialism coalition
over middle school tribal concerns over
who sits
at what lunch table i laughed out loud
at that one
glenn greenwald independent journalist
at sub stack joins us now glenn
why do these uh self-appointed
gatekeepers prefer
absolute conformity over productive
alliances
well i think that the end of your
monologue referenced
exactly the reason there are two kinds
of people broadly speaking to pay
attention to politics
one who actually care about the
ability to change the society and the
political
climate for the better to improve
people's lives by doing things like
bringing troops home and freeing up the
billions upon billions of dollars that
we spend
on imperialism and deploying troops all
around the world that does no good for
american citizens there are people who
care about
making the society better and therefore
want to form coalitions majoritarian
coalitions to effectuate that change
with whoever is on board with their view
on that issue like ro khanna did when he
went on your show last night
and then there's a separate group of
people that form a large sector of the
media
that don't care about using politics to
change society
at all they only see it for their own
careerism or for their ability to
create branding and image about
themselves as good people
and what they have an interest in is
keeping us all in separate corners
hating one another doped up on fear
and hatred of every other every other
tribe
so that we just constantly stay addicted
to their media outlets
and that nothing ever changes and that's
what the people at vox and media matters
are like that's why they employ people
whose only
job in the world is to serve as hall
monitors watching tv
24 hours a day principally fox to
tattletail
on any democrat or leftist or liberal
i'm sure they're doing it right now
taking little screenshots of me putting
it up talking to you
like they did with congressman connor
because they don't want
any challenges to the ruling coalition
which is the establishment wing of both
parties they want us to avoid
realizing that we actually do have a lot
in common on critical issues
yeah i mean i got hammered over the
years
after i kind of you know changed my
thinking on the iraq war and i
just came out and i said i i think i got
it wrong
i mean i i love our troops i support our
troops i
you know was over in iraq i did the
first national broadcast
uh radio broadcast from iraq and the
guys there a lot of them were saying
this isn't working and i almost didn't
want to believe them
uh but it became you know very apparent
uh that we were
we were in a heap of trouble there and
it's uh but it made it uncomfortable a
lot of people wouldn't talk to me they
like they stopped talking to me and the
republicans some of them still haven't
talked to me
but i don't really care i know you don't
care uh but i think a lot of people they
want to get their bills paid and
you know it's it's easier being in the
establishment it's a lot easier
yeah and well and not only that there
are a lot of people who benefit from
these policies just not
american citizens if you know one of the
things that was so eye opening for me is
i watched all 14 hours of the house
armed services committee
hearing about six months ago to approve
this massive military budget where the
u.s spends
more than the next 12 countries combined
now where does that money go
it goes to raytheon and general dynamics
and boeing not to the american workers
not to people who are suffering in the
middle of a pandemic with joblessness
and rent delinquencies
and if you look at the people on that
house services committee who wanted to
prevent president trump
from withdrawing troops from afghanistan
a 19 year old war the longest war in
american history
or to withdraw troops from germany why
are they there in germany the idea was
to prevent incursions into western
europe by soviet union which no longer
exists
the coalition that formed were these
pockish pro-war democrats
funded by boeing in general dynamics who
joined with the neocons like liz cheney
republicans who want endless war and
then you had this other coalition trying
to stop them which was congressman
khanna and tulsi gabbard who actually
served in iraq and understands the
savagery and waste of war working with
people like
congressman matt gates one of the most
fervent supporters of president
trump so if you're somebody who wants
yeah if you're somebody who wants to
actually stop these wars rather than
posturing as a good person
of course you're going to find anyone
that you can
to put an end to these kinds of policies
that run roughshod over the interests of
the american people
all for the benefit of corporations and
wall street that fund the establishment
wing of both parties
but you got you get the sense don't you
that especially
the the squad i mean the aoc is on the
cover of vogue
nothing wrong with that or vanity fair
one i can't remember which one was one
of the big magazines
but she's going to have to make a choice
at some point
right i mean either be bought off by the
establishment eventually
or may form these alliances with people
maybe she doesn't like on a lot of issue
or most issues
if she's truly going to be a figure for
you know the working people and anti-war
people
yeah i mean you know what's so
interesting when she when congresswoman
acosta cortez
opposed and denounced vehemently
governor cuomo's plan in new york to
give
billions and billions of tax dollars of
tax breaks to amazon they're one of the
richest corporations in the world one of
the most predatory as well
one of the people who stood up and
defended her most was
tucker carlson on you this network and
there weren't very many people defending
her
elsewhere because governor cuomo was a
popular democratic governor
and when i interviewed her when she was
running against joe crowley in the
primaries one of the things she was
saying was that loyalty to the
democratic party
actually prevents us from getting things
done because the democratic party is not
on the side
of workers or ordinary americans they're
on the side of wall street
and corporations and silicon valley so
she knows that the question is can she
break out of this prison
prison that they try and put you in that
says
it's better to fail and only talk to
people on your side
than to succeed and create coalitions
and that's what really they're trying to
enforce
and that's the reason why they try and
ostracize anyone who talks across
the aisle yeah you're going to get
trashed glenn for coming on the show
tonight
i promise you that's that's just for
sure i mean we can write their tweets
for them
and respond to them glenn thank you so
much for coming on tonight we really
appreciate it